ja acht jahre nach ihrem tod hat endlich
der mordprozess im fall maria böhmer
begonnen ihr verlobter der
krankenpfleger christian f soll maria
erst betäubt haben und dann womöglich
sogar lebendig begraben haben im wald
überführt dieser sparten maria berners
verlobten im mordprozess vor dem
landgericht regensburg beginnt heute die
beweisaufnahme vor sieben jahren
entdeckten pilzsammler wolfgang die
überreste der 26-jährigen im kreuther
forst neben der leiche lag ein feder
sparten das gleiche modell hatte marias
verlobt zahl christian f nur vier tage
vor ihrem verschwinden gekauft wolfgang
o sagt im prozess als erster zeuge aus
an dem tag war er mit bekannten im wald
unterwegs und erinnert sich genau an den
schrecklichen fund
ich habe ihn stetig sehen und gehen
knoche von schenkel gedacht dass kein
tier so umgesehen den sparten liegen
sehen und eine leere wasserflasche nach
ich sagt freunde raus hier
das ist ein menschliches skelett mir ist
schon damals auffallen dass das sehr
schön ausgegraben war recht also beim
sport muss das gewesen sein
die grube ausgehoben und ich nehme an
dass tiere
die knochen gang freigelegt haben sonst
hätten sie nie gesehen
der 67-jährige hoffnung dass durch seine
aussage der schuldige überführt werden
kann
ja und die 26 jährige maria wurde eben
lang vermisst wir haben es gerade gehört
erst 16 monate später konnte ihr skelett
im wald von einem pilzsammler entdeckt
werden
wir wollen jetzt schalten zu meinen
kollegen jörg völkerling du bist für uns
in regensburg und der paid sammler der
die leiche damals entdeckt hat ist jetzt
beide aber heute hat ja zunächst die
beweisaufnahme im prozess begonnen wie
das abgelaufen
der vorsitzende richter michael hammer
geht in diesem verfahren streng
chronologisch vor das heißt er beginnt
mit dem auffinden der leiche am 8
september 2013
heute sind dafür kriminalbeamte und
polizisten geladen die als erstes an
diesem fundort im kreuther forst kamen
sie haben geschildert wie sie da den
sparten gesichert haben und ihm die spur
nummer 1.10 gegeben haben neben den
knochenresten sie haben geschildert wie
sie aus diesen 50 zentimeter tiefen noch
einzelne knochenteile herausgeholt haben
auch ein schulterblatt und ein stück von
der wirbelsäule und wie in ihrem
hinterkopf als sie dorthin gerufen
wurden waren sofort schon der fall maria
böhmer war
denn maria böhmer war am vorabend ihres
verschwindens mit ihrem verlobten auf
einem reiterhof ganz in der nähe dort
wurde sie zuletzt um 23 uhr lebend
gesehen
und neben mir ist jetzt der mann der
damals diese leiche gefunden hat der
pilzsammler wolfgang urban ski aus
neumarkt gleich können sie einfach noch
mal schildern was für eine situation
haben sie damals in kräuter fonds zum
beispiel zusammen gewesen und dann hat
mich jemand gerufen sagen ich komme hier
guck mal was ist das eigentlich im
gebüsch reingegangen und dann habe ich
an einem schädel gesehen und knochen
namens ein bisschen umgeguckt und dann
haben auf der rechten seite einigen
sparten entdeckt und eine leere
wasserflasche manchmal sogar gewesen und
das ist ein
kriminelle ort dann müssen wir raus raus
hier nichts verändern lassen uns liegen
die beim rausgehen unterwegs war mal bei
yoga gefragt wo die nächste polizeiwache
wäre
wir haben gleich abgewunken und dann
habe ich gedacht okay dann muss man 110
wählen
da habe ich die angewählt die dame am
anderen ende die konnte aber momentan
nichts finden wo wir das sind und auch
gesagt dass sollen die kollegen nach
berner 2 kommen auch mit der parkplatz
und da stehe ich dann mit den kollegen
hinter und zeigt ihnen den ort den
fundort eingetroffen sind
dann hat er ja gleich gesagt er der eine
beamte da muss ich jetzt stimmt kann ich
nicht weg gehen
das ist ein menschliches skelett und mir
sind dann raus gegangen und dann haben
die bei uns draußen die personalien
aufgenommen
zum späteren zeitpunkt wurde dann ein
auge haben und alles abgeklärt und so
weiter und so fort war damals schon der
fall maria baumann ihrem hinterkopf
nein ich wusste von diesem fall nichts
es ist erst im nachhinein gekommen
da haben uns unterhalten dass man da
eben gefunden haben wie gesagt auch und
xy bei was da ist jemand verschwunden
das müsste die bauma sein
und dann hat sage heißen sollte in den
blumen geben aber da war nichts drin die
wir sowieso noch vier geteilt worden ist
dann egal
auf alle fälle haben wir dann das so
weiter nichts mehr gehört und die
beerdigung gab am abend bei der polizei
erbeten dass ich den termin haben möchte
wenn die maria beigesetzt wird
das haben wir nämlich als pflicht an
gesehen dass wir da und da einfinden und
ihre die letzte ehre geben herzlichen
dank herr urban ski dass sie das möglich
gemacht haben und dass wir uns einen
einblick vermittelt haben als erster
zeuge hat sie wie gesagt der pilzsammler
heute hier ausgesagt es werden jetzt
noch 63 weitere zeugen in den nächsten
25 verhandlungstage hier ihre aussage
machen müssen
danke schön hier völkerling aus
regensburg